طيب اللي يعرفني يعرف علاقتي القويه مع
الغناء
كمستمع فقط يعني كان نفسي يكون عندي موهبه
اكبر من كده بس للاسف يعني قدر الله وما
شاء فعل هذا اللي موجود يعني فريق تفاعلكم
حاب انه يذكرني بوجع وحسرتي ويذكروني زي
ما دايما بيذكروني تقريبا كل يوم لما اغني
لهم انه صوتي بالشعر واختاروا انه نختم
حلقه ملخص السنه باجمل الاصوات النجوم
اللي كانوا ضيوفنا السنه فانا اترككم
الاصوات الجميله
ان شاء الله في امان الله مشاهدينا
يا بحر يا ابو الاسرار مثلك مثل اللي
الي
مشتاق لهن قلبي على نار بدي شوف
الغوالي وخدني صوب وديني اشلحني عندهن
ونسينا
بتفعلك كل سنين
وبقضي عمري يغني لك
قد عمري يغني
همم
اشوف فيك يوم
على اللي انت عملته فيا
لما انت غدرت بيها
واللي بترضى عليا بكره النهارده عليك
تذكر اي شيء
[موسيقى]
وان كان يحصلك
تناسيها ايش عجب قاطع بيه يا راحتي
النفسيه
تدري القلب
[موسيقى]
مش هيفرق في الخصام ده لو عينيك صدفه عيني
امشي وما ترميني سلام
واتنسيت كاني ماجيت ولو حسيتها تكسري
ودارت في قلبي مشيت على عيني تغار مني
عطشان يا برق السماء بموت من طول الغياب
بموت من كثر الظما وانا على متن السحاب
خطاك في عيوني صوره حبك بقلبي من تحت
مكتوب ومقدر كتاب نكشف حجري ما بيننا الله
عليك
[موسيقى]
لسه انا عندي الخلاف حرفنه